I personally believe that we are already
today over-regulated and I'm talking now
hear about the real economy I'm not
talking about the financial industry
which is a different discussion I have
pointed out in public and I have pointed
out to the most important politician of
this world that whatever they are doing
now g20 don't forget that this crisis
has not been provoked by the real
economy this crisis has made the real
economy a victim of the financial crisis
and not the other way around we have
enough regulation after Andrew I have at
that time said I think we are already
over regulated doesn't make any sense to
have 9,000 pages of regulation how you
run a company we would rather have some
very good principles and live up to
these principles then to have this
over-regulated things which at the end
of the day has not has not prevented any
other crisis so yes it has pre it has
provoked that the productivity since
this over regulation has come into into
into life if you look at the
productivity of the real economy it has
gone back because sports management have
been more occupied with complying with
regulation then with increasing
productivity and increasing the living
standards of the consumers I think they
already over regulated we don't need
more we need less regulation today and
we should be refocusing what I think the
real economy is all about which is
creating wealth and better living
standard for our consumers all over the
world regulations will never ever
prevent fraud or criminal behavior
because if that was the case we wouldn't
have them out because we have laws we
have reclamation achieved a bit so to
think that you can regulate every single
thing and with this you would have human
beings behaving in a
mana is udupi this is not realistic okay
so what you really have to do is to come
back and to think what is the most
important part of governance now it is
my personal opinion that the most
important part if I talking now about
corporate governance is to establish a
very strong a very strong basically
board of directors I don't believe that
and so-called shohola shareholder
democracy is the right answer to that I
don't think that shareholders and the
whole setup are being conceived in order
to exercise the control function that's
why we have the board of directors and
it is not because one or the other board
of directors has not been working or
whether there were issues of what I
would call internal corruption or things
like this that therefore the model
doesn't work I think our model is still
working very well you have the
shareholders who have the ultimate
responsibility the exercise is ultimate
responsibility through their voting
rights which they should be using
strongly and consciously and then
afterwards delegate the power of the of
the control function of the execution
function to a strong strong board and if
the board is not behaving well you
always have the possibility to eliminate
the board members you don't have to
reelect the board members so I think
strengthening of the board not weakening
of the board is one of the crucial
elements of what we are where we should
be going into the future
you